انسان
انه يتوقع قرارات قويه بشان امتداد بلاده
بمزيد من الاسلحه الغربيه خلال اجتماع
الحلفاء في المانيا اليوم
سماه ترددها في الاذن بامداد اوكرانيا
بدبابات
الغربيه الحديثه التي نتفق على توريدها مع
الشركاء وقد شكل بالفعل تحالف وشركاه ونحن
الان ننتظر قرارا فعليا من عاصمه اوروبيه
واحده ينشط سلاسل التعاون بشان الدبابات
اعتقد ان صلابه القياده الالمانيه ستبقى
دون تغيير ونحن نستعد للقاء رامز
دفعه قويه من الدعم العسكري من الولايات
المتحده
معنى الان من المقر الاجتماعي بقاعده
رمشتاين الجويه العسكريه الامريكيه غرب
المانيا مراسل الجزيره عيسى طيب عيسى همم
اهلا بك ونيته يتعهد بمزيد من الدعم
الاوكراني ولكن هناك تحفظ اوكرانيه على
الموقف الالماني هي الذي يصفه بالموقف
المتردد
الحقيقه يعني الغرب الان ينتظر المانيا في
هذه النقطه بالذات وهي نقطه
الدبابه المقاتله العملاقه الاثنين وهي
ايضا مفصل مهم في امراه اينشتاين المانيا
جاءت الى اينشتاين واحد نعم مستعده لتقديم
دبابه برادي اثنين الى اوكرانيا لكن بشرط
ان تقدم الولايات المتحده ايضا الدباباتها
القتاليه العملاقه لذلك هذا الامر هو ايضا
في الصلب الاجتماعي او في اولويه
الاجتماعيه اليوم الحديث الثاني وهو الكشف
عن الاسلحه التي امس تمت الولايات المتحده
اعلنت عنها في في
الكشف عن بعض انواع هذه الاسلحه والتي
تقدر قيمتها بنحو اثنين مليار ونصف ومن
بينها على سبيل المثال
ثمانيه تنظيمات دفاع جوي مركبات براديا
القتاليه هناك 20 مدخل لنقل التجون مصفحه
هناك اكثر من 600 طلقه مدفعيه متعدده
الاغراض هناك قرابه 1800 من الانظمه
المصاحبه هناك ايضا صواريخ مواجهه بالليزر
اسلحه كثيره وترسانه ضخمه الولايات
المتحده تم الكشف عنها في رامشتاين ايضا
الان المتحدث باسم الباندا كون قال
للجزيره بان الاجتماع هناك اجتماع رفيع
المستوى بين بين وزاره الدفاع وبين على
مستوى وزاره الدفاع بين الولايات المتحده
واوكرانيا بدا الان وايضا اجتماعات
التنسيقيه بين الخبراء والقيادات العسكريه
الامريكيه والاوكرانيه وهي مستمره همم
لمتابعه الوضع ايضا تحدث باسم الباندا جون
للجزيره بان نحو 40 دوله شاركت في هذه
النسخه وهو رقم
جدا لان العدد يتجاوز همم الناتو بحيث ان
المشاركين ايضا من خارج مظله الناتو
الحديث الاخر وهو ما مد التزام الاعضاء
اليوم
بالمساهمه الماليه لان الامر لا يقدر يوقف
فقط عند الاسلحه والاسلحه النوعيه
والدبابات القتاليه العملاقه ايضا
يتجاوز ذلك الى مثلا الدعم المال هناك
خلاف الا غايات هذه اللحظه لا يعرف ما مدى
اتفاق المجموعه هل ستستطيع ان تتوافق في
حزم مساعده اخرى علاج اوكرانيا ام لا
الامر الاخر ال- ال- الما ماذا توافق
الامريكي الى المانيا هل سيتم الوصول الى
اتفاق مشترك واعلام مشترك لارسال الدبابه
الامريكيه القتاليه والدبابه همم
الالمانيه القتاليه براديا اثنين تزامنا
في اعلان واحد مشترك وهذا الذي طلبت به
المانيا هل سيتم الوف بي خلال هذه
الاجتماعات هناك حديث بانه نعم سيتم
الوفاء به لكن لا شيء مضمون خصوصا مع
اصرار المستشار الالماني الا تذهب الماني
منفرده بدعم اوكرانيا بهكذا سلاح رغم
الانتقادات التي وجهها امس الرئيس
الاوكراني لكن برلين ماتزله تصر بان
المنظومه الدفاع عفوا منظومه الدفاع
ومنظومه الاسلحه النوعيه
ينبغي ان تكون الشراكه مع الشركه وخصوصا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك عيسى الطيبين المقر
الاجتماع بقاعده رمشتاين الجويه العسكريه
الامريكيه الغربيه المانيا